you know very often sales people and
entrepreneurs do not fully know what
makes a great customer and a bad
customer because all they think about
when they think about a great customers
whoever made them the most money so
today i'm going to give you examples of
three different customers john who made
you 50k commission larry who made you 20
000 in commission mary who only made you
5 000 in commission but i'm going to
share with you why mary is your best
customer as well as what bad customers
to stay away from
so let's first start off by identifying
what a bad customer is you know we have
the best customer the worst customer
what makes a bad customer a bad customer
i've had tens of thousands of customers
over the years and i've worked with a
lot of personalities and the moment i
see trends of somebody potentially being
a bad customer i immediately have to
make a decision whether i want to pour
into this person or do i have to pivot
here are some of the qualities see if
you relate number one they're never
happy no matter what you do for these
bad customers no matter what you ever do
they're never happy number two they're
too demanding number three it's a small
payday number four they take up way too
much of your time five integrity issues
six high touch low payoff you spend so
many hours calling this person spending
time with them for a hundred dollar
payday number seven abusive to your
staff every time she calls in or he
calls in they disrespect your assistant
they disrespect the people that are
everybody's at fault everybody does
something uh wrong where your staff
feels like they're walking on eggshells
trying to service this customer number
eight try to game the system and last
but not least constant threats meaning
every time they're like we're about to
leave you we're gonna go we're gonna do
this you're like do i even have you or
do i not have you these are qualities of
worst customers you may have experienced
it if you haven't these are some of the
signs don't jump to conclusion right
after about when somebody does it let it
be a trend where you all of a sudden see
a pattern to say i think this person
qualifies to be in this area so now
let's set them aside let's look at john
larry and mary so john
client comes in
easy you sell them fifty thousand dollar
payday like wait a minute what
super successful has many different
options won't give you any referrals
zero relationship with them when you
call them you can never get a hold of
them but he made you fifty thousand
dollars okay so he put some time into
him he came in hey here's what i want
this is what i'm looking for maybe you
sold them a three million dollar house
maybe you sold them a two million dollar
house maybe sold them a 10 million
insurance policy maybe did a deal with
them whatever business you're in but you
made a lot of money biggest client ever
okay number two larry okay this guy
comes in he makes you twenty thousand
dollars commission five-year follow-up
took you five years to follow with larry
until he said yes so five years divided
by twenty thousand four thousand dollars
per year if you really break it down
he's creating momentum in his business
which means he's about to have a lot of
success he's not at the success level of
john very friendly and he's got a young
network hasn't sent you a lot of
referrals but he's got a young network
so today if you compare these two he
send you some referrals he send you zero
zero referrals 50k 20 000. now let's
talk about mary here's mary mary
she loves what you do she loves what you
stand for she's a total believer in you
she can only afford to buy a six hundred
thousand dollar house from you she can
only afford to buy a small policy from
you she can only afford to buy something
very minimal from you where the
commission's only five thousand dollars
right however because she's a believer
in you she sent you 28 referrals these
28 referrals have made you 111 thousand
dollars and she tells everybody about
you so on the surface john's the best
customer
larry's the second best customer mary's
not even one of your best customers
but the reality is mary is your best
customer period she's easy to deal with
you call her she picks up she tells
everybody about you she invites you to
the birthday party she invites you to
the different events and she's
constantly working for you see
the difference the reason why this
conversation came about i was sitting
there with a couple of my sales guys
were having a sales meeting and i said
give me the list your top five best
customers and everybody wrote down their
top five customers
i said tell me why you made your number
one your number one oh because he made
me 160 thousand dollars why is your
number one number one because number one
made me 88 thousand dollars why is your
number one number one everybody give me
their number one and i said so tell me
why number five is number five oh
because he only made me 13 000
tell me why your number five is this and
i said so let me ask you a different
question here tell me which one of your
clients have given you the most
referrals that's turned into business so
the same guy that had a customer that
made him 160 had another one that he put
at the bottom as number five best
customer he says number five best
customer gave me 20
referrals who all bought and all spend a
minimum of ten to fifteen thousand
dollars those twenty referrals that he
gave and made him two hundred fifty
thousand dollars even though the client
only spent fifteen or twenty thousand
dollars i said that's your best customer
you need to know what a best customer is
with a with ten clients like this you
can become a millionaire with ten
clients like mary you can become a
millionaire so now if you're watching
this you're saying well first of all you
may have a referral problem you don't
even ask for referrals but then you got
to get better at a script on how to ask
referrals you go oh my gosh i totally
thought a person like this was the best
customer so do you mean i don't help
them anymore no of course you supported
john who's not going to take a 50 000
commission anybody would take a fifty
thousand dollar commission or twenty or
five but you water this one the most
because this one's working for you this
one just sees you as somebody to do
business with and that's it so now a few
things to think about on great customers
your return on time they're easy to deal
with they give you referrals they're
constantly giving you connections
they're constantly having influences
they have specialized knowledge that you
can learn from okay so in here from mary
i'm getting a lot of contacts a lot of
connections this one doesn't even want
to have a relationship with me this one
wants to have a relationship with me so
believe it or not mary's your best
customer larry is your second best
customer and john's your third best
customer in this example because he is
headed going places and he doesn't mind
inviting you and he's very friendly with
you and he's a guy that's winning and
he's willing to spend time with you
because his contacts could eventually be
your contacts he's your two best
customers john's your third best
customer having said that i got two
other videos i want you to watch if you
enjoyed this video and got a lot of
value from it on sale so if you got
value give it a thumbs up subscribe to
the channel two other videos one of the
other ones it's three skills every sales
person must master three skills
great sales people master if you've
never seen this click over here the
other one is the difference between
customer service and customer experience
it's a very very different
way of looking at customer service this
video was shared at microsoft and they
were teaching customer experience and
customer service based on this video at
microsoft if you've never seen it click
on that to watch it thank you everybody
bye
[Music]